now comic book heroes and action films
we kind of assume they appeal to kind of
nerdy boys essentially yeah and you kind
of forget there are lots of nerdy women
out there like these films yeah
everyone's got that in a nerd yeah well
you are a proper nerd on you I mean when
it comes to Harry Potter I'm a massive
massive nerd we know that because you
posted this book is this your 12th or
thought well vote 13 here this is Margot
Robbie look how on cool hardback Harry
Potter do you know what's particularly
pathetic about this picture a couple
things really let you point them out
number one it's my birthday that's how I
chose to spend my birthday what was in
the cup number 2 I'm drinking tea number
3 I'm wearing glasses even though I
don't need glasses I lied to the
optometrist because I wanted to have
glasses what you were where are you
gonna hide what if I don't know I love
Harry Potter I just to get round to read
in the last one okay so not just ours
but I saw stir doom
when I'll just uh I'll do it layin and
are you kidding me so you've read one to
six and you haven't read the seven yeah
I don't know are you actually kidding
baby bear for twin I'm not gonna be able
to sleep tonight what worrying about is
a game you mean it's just you keep it on
the edge I mean this is insane for me do
you know another fun fact my husband
it's your thing this is sorry I brought
this up
sorry I'll stop hijacking the job let go
because I'm not here my husband is in
the Harry Potter movies I know I was
like had you told me sooner we would
have married very quickly but he was an
extra he was saying when he was a little
kid he's like one of his slow that are
not extras you know when Draco like
pushes some kids out of the way to to
see Buckbeak in the third book yeah he
pushes my husband out tell me were you
ever an extra in hi Potter no not
someone I had it my friend was an extra
at school and then I asked him like
how'd you get into acting and he didn't
tell me so you posted a picture of
yourself as I don't know how old you are
you're a little boy here yeah and you
look like you could be in Hogwarts here
you are
[Applause]
you showed me that when we were filming
I feel better about my photo now it's
gorgeous yeah I know people you went to
school with must be so surprised lose a
film star Daniel
[Music]
you